at Number 17 father-and-son team John
and Matt Hoback set up the ultimate bug
experiment at their Texas home it's a
face-off between two of the most
voracious predators in their backyard a
giant spider versus a giant wasp let the
battle begin
I like wrestling but this was the
ultimate wrestling match let's get ready
to bump
the spider has to neutralize the wasp
and make it no longer a threat as fast
as possible because the wasp still can't
sting the spider once the wasp is
started to get covered it has no hope it
can't get out because the silk is so
incredibly strong and tight so once the
spider wins what will she do with her
prize the whole point of spinning a web
for the spider is to catch a dinner and
eat dinner it digests on the outside of
its body it actually excretes these
digestive juices onto the wasp and the
juices break down the wasp meat and then
the spider slurps it back into itself
it's impossible for the wasp to escape
but what stops this spider from getting
stuck in her own sticky silk trap the
spider web is actually made of a lot of
different types of webbing you have the
radial threads and the spiral threads
and the spiral ones are actually the
sticky ones and the radio ones are not
and the spider knows that it should walk
on the radial threads and not on the
spiral threads and that's how it doesn't
get stuck itself for showing us the
awesome powers of spider silk John and
Matt earned the spider a waspy meal and
themselves a place in our countdown